this may come as a bit of a shocker
don't have a lot of friends love shut
off
Denny do you want to go to the [ __ ]
ceiling I'm not playing around with you
Danny today for the first time in my
life I'm going to a house party we're
playing house party the game made from
the famous developer eeeek LLC games
it's a great game it's a really really
really really good game starting a new
game oh my god oh my god here we are
oh okay I'm a little nervous okay don't
mess this up pills you can do this you
can do this this is the this is the
[ __ ] standard room in the unity by the
way okay okay whatever
all right let's say let's go in and oh
hello hello hello
whoa she's dancing on the coffee table
my god those moves Danny could you dance
like that sorry you got a little spit on
you you may not know this about me but
I'm actually an excellent dancer and
I've been I've been waiting for a time
to really break down my moves
[Music]
dabbe whoa whoa what is wrong with your
hair what is wrong with it
oh god she's dancing - hello how you
doing Oh
oh sorry I didn't I think I'm supposed
to talk to this girl Madison that's it
talk um do I know you no but I would
like to get to know you a little better
oh that's sweet I'm Madison Madison can
you stop can you just stop what the [ __ ]
is this oh just like I'm sorry man I'm
sorry Madison I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll
get your phone I'll get your phone I
have a third hand hey hey okay good game
good game everyone very exciting game
very very exciting game playing master
bathroom okay there we go
take it Madison's phone got it
we're doing great I think we're blending
in really well in this party what do you
guys think it's not a real party ceiling
ceiling you will go to the [ __ ]
ceiling kill yourself such natural
movement she has wow wow she really
knows how to work it oh my god good game
good game everyone
[Music]
all right uh here at Madison I have you
can you can you chill no sweat no sweat
no sweat no sweat no sweat what she want
us to do aren't you a bold one help me
play a prank on my sister okay humiliate
Ashley Ashley Ashley how about dad
how about what a great party I'm having
a great time there's Ashley there's
Ashley Ashley Ashley s customer Ashley
come back come out oh god what happened
wait I can grab the chair whoa holy [ __ ]
man would you like a chair Ashley how
about you are how about a pizza would
you like a pizza there you go are they
where'd she go Ashley Ashley I have a
pizza
Ashley wake up come it just open your
mouth Ashley I got it for you I got it
for you trust me I think she likes oh
okay all right
hi I'm Ashley I'm Madison sister you're
Madison sister I never would have
guessed you're way hotter than she is
oh thanks that's really sweet thanks for
making fun of my sister I [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] no sweat no fun oh no sweat
my super sister Madison spilled beer on
me okay what a [ __ ] can you tone it
down all right can you tone it the [ __ ]
down over there all right so what do we
do with her then can I help you out with
this beer accident you help me right now
I'm dripping wet and eautiful dripping
what she's dripping wet no matter what a
gimme sec I'm on it I'm on it
Ashley I'm on it don't you work
the [ __ ] is this sonic cat hi Madison
I'm on your quest I met your sister
she's up to something I know it
are you drunk no what Oh God
I'm straight edge I can't stand [ __ ]
who get drunk at parties okay
does anyone want a pizza anyone want a
pizza take it take it take that pizza
come on I know just swallow just swallow
you want that god damn it Frank you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up Frank
no no no don't touch Patrick Noonan
don't touch Patrick Patrick run run
Patrick oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no Patrick get up get up I'll get the
pizza I'll get the pizza Patrick I'll
get the pizza it's gonna be okay hang in
there buddy
hang in there buddy I have the pizza the
pizza will stop [ __ ] Patrick what are
you doing
Patrick fight you got a fight again you
gotta get up get up
got it
[Music]
oh my god it's getting [ __ ]
stop stop fighting stop this oh my god
not even close you're [ __ ] with you
stop stop please stop making that face
you're scaring me you're scaring the
chill
go my god okay oh I think it's dead he
died out of plant rest implant rest
implant Patrick here have a pizza have a
pizza think about what you do there we
go okay I saw Frank checking out your
ass oh wait that was me yeah oh stop it
haha you're funny good one good one if
it's any consolation wet clothes - no
you're still adorable no sweat no sweat
no sweat no sweat
any luck of finding me a way to try off
what if we give her the towel perfect
thanks this clothes still smell really
bad okay I could wash them you do that
for me I'm not sure if I can trust you
that what can I do
bring me Madison's diary
Shahla and Shay accepted I can lay down
on bed excellent good game remove shirt
oh yeah hey don't laugh what are you
don't laugh don't clap like that please
oh my gosh you took my [ __ ] spot what
are you strong with you lay down great
great I can't see her
Hey look
remove boxes remove pants whoa whoa whoa
no no no put on your goddamn pants put
on goddamn it goddamn it put on your
pants put on pants what the [ __ ] am I
looking at what the [ __ ] god damn it god
right thank you thank you
look that was a close call oh he's okay
now he's back alive
great all right so without looking
online or or cheating you have to pick
this pen right you have to get this pen
it's a really good game by the way I'm
really enjoying it
uh you have to get this paper uh-huh
okay and then where you're supposed to
do is you put that you put the paper
right [ __ ] here and then you put you
put the pencil over and then you get the
code to the [ __ ] locker and then you
go here it's good game by the way it's
RIT it's really good and then you put
this on this [ __ ] lock great what the
actual [ __ ] that's my diary I'm gonna
get Frank you're dead [ __ ] no no
we cannot let her go to Frank we cannot
let her go to Frank
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] don't get Frank don't get
Frank
Madison Ashley Ashley save me piece of
[ __ ] mean frankerz friends me and
Frank's are friends with friends for
friends got damn it we're friends so you
can't stop us you can't stop us Ashley
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Frank it's not it's not true it's not
true don't listen to her do not listen
to her Frank
do not listen don't don't look
look Frank look at me I'm dead okay
great
Frank please we can work this out we can
work this out Frank we can work this out
it doesn't have to end like this Frank
you were like a father to me Frank
you were supposed to be the chosen one
okay
is he coming great excellent just what I
wanted
please I have a child what go down got
him come on I'm not gonna have to replay
everything god [ __ ] damn it god
[ __ ] damn it
[Music]
okay so it looks like we're alone here
just give me your dress and I'll get the
washing machine can you shut the door
first okay yeah we're still in the
hallway give me give me your clothes my
pleasure
oh my god oh my god oh my god
my co-productions is sponsoring this
video this is an ad ad for my protection
okay uh your panties looks like they're
soaked - want me to throw them in the
wash today's your lucky day score no
sweat no sweat no sweat okay so we put
her clothes and here then oh she's naked
okay good good job good job
[ __ ] off Ashley you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't love her like I do
hey crazy dance like what the [ __ ] is
that move here take a seat take a
[ __ ] seat take a seat right there
Oh someone's liking it Hey oh my god
it's finished yes
let's give her a close we did it bro
high-five finally okay so what do you
say pay me back for saving your life
with
[Music]
maybe if we go somewhere private I guess
that makes sense
hey hey here come on all right now let's
close the door talk alright pay me back
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
no thanks I'm saving myself for marriage
hahaha oh you dumb [ __ ] how do I get
out of this situation
I can I literally can what end huh [ __ ]
ah you got blade
she got played God
[Music]
this has been my very first house party
did you enjoyed watching if you did
leave a like why don't you go ahead and
leave to likes just to as a social
experiment and see what happens have you
ever been to a house party do you have
any fun stories to share please leave a
comment down below and save yourself for
marriage